[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut à tous bienvenue pour cette alors
attends il y a écrit 10e partie c'est la
onzième
attention le Fab ça va ça va et toi tu
étais où en plus là
je fais la blague pour la 250e
entre Fabien ibisier
le nom entier
[Musique]
des lettres quoi t'inquiète pas j'ai
l'habitude je sais taper ton nom
facilement
et le F ça te va par contre dessus
mais je m'en fous complètement
en fait il y a pas beaucoup de pièges
une fois que tu sais que c'est le S et
le Z
bah c'est facile quoi
il y a plus de piège non
mais
c'est vrai que le nom est quand même
donc des fois tu as des formulaires tu
es limité à 10 lettres tu es mal et ça
t'arrive de tomber sur des formulaires
limites
et tu fais comment
c'est joli aussi après
a priori nous ont inversé les câbles
aussi ça n'est pas en haut
faut-il qu'elle marche encore mais
j'aime bien la photo de nepo c'est même
mieux que la caméra en fait avec son
chignon
bon on va attendre le premier cours
probablement une Espagnole aujourd'hui
attends oui oui
bon mais sinon c'est surprenant mais on
sait jamais
ça peut repartir en français ça peut
être tout et n'importe quoi moi je
m'attendais 4 ou 5
en tout cas c'est joué c'était plus ou
moins sûr
E5 tu vois on avait vu juste ce matin
petit déj et on avait pensé que ce
serait une énième berlinoise après Baki
il a dit que la berlinoise il pensait
que ça pouvait partir en finale
de la berlinoise ok pourquoi pas donc ça
reparti en espagnol en tout cas donc
peut-être ça peut repartir en 6
je serai sur berlinois
7 c'était pas si bête de le 3 ou 4
il m'a dit que vous pouvez le jouer
aujourd'hui alors
il m'a dit pour une partie ça peut ne
pas être bête
il a plutôt sué depuis le début du match
donc
il avait raison il avait pas senti une
répétition à la berlinoise il m'a dit
ils vont avoir trop peur de la finale
oui mais en fait pourquoi
je la joue une fois en surprise mais
c'était plus une surprise elle était
dans les vices
je sais plus de qui ce matin mais de
quelqu'un d'influence qui a dit que les
lits avaient un plus grand rôle que
prévu dans le match je sais pas quoi
bon
ce qu'on veut bien laisser croire ou je
sais pas quoi mais c'est vrai que Yann
il a dit qui ouais
[Musique]
ça donne deux trois idées quand même je
veux dire évidemment c'est pas le
fichier anti avec toutes les analyses
mais tu as
tu as un bon petit Intel quoi
ouais ça c'est Niels que nous ne le
pensions enfin moi j'ai toujours pensé
que ça lui faisait du mal bah oui
bon ben on a l'ouverture prévue
à trois on l'avait eu ou pas déjà ce à
trois l'autre jour
[Musique]
alors sur la 3 qu'est-ce que ça vaut mon
Fab ah mais c'est
une des grandes lignes
c'est bon bah pour pas comme ça sur
quelle est la 5 tu as la case à deux
pour le fou
donc en gros voilà et il était parti
plus sur du C3
donc j'étais là
[Musique]
au début non en fait on va dire au début
donc
je vais la regarder je vais te dire
exactement comme ça on va lâcher une
info
c'est pour garder le fou sur cette
diagonale
donc bon tu peux pas te le faire
échanger donc ton plan c'est moins de
jouer pour ces trois d'écart même si
parfois ça peut arriver mais la casser 3
souvent le truc par le cavalier en fait
pour les sauter sur des 5 il y a Maxime
qui avait joué ça beaucoup de mail
pendant un moment en fait
[Musique]
donc en gros c'est ça le truc alors bon
je viens les Noirs rock mais ils peuvent
jouer avec évaluer à 5 et 5,8 avant même
rock il y a deux trois petites
différences mais bon principalement les
Noirs souvent rock on va dire
ici
sur quoi donc ici le coup
et là plusieurs plusieurs setups pour
les Noirs donc au début il devait
beaucoup fouger 4
pour faire cadd4 tu peux pas éviter mais
tu fais faut trois comme ça s'il vient
des quatre tu le bouche
puis on prend et tu fais qu'il y ait des
cinq et par contre on a vu ça beaucoup
dans le match Maxime faudra rognan en
Coupe du monde
donc j'en position mais en fait ça s'est
passé de mode c'est plutôt un peu plus
sympa pour les blancs bon même si ça
doit être quand même acceptable pour les
Noirs mais ils ont trouvé mieux voilà
ils font plus du tout
mais je crois que ça peut-être toute
cette fameuse position là un peu à la
con là tu peux pas prendre racisme
je crois
bon bref en fait ça tu as une meilleure
structure dès que tu changes de
nouvelles pièces mineures sont bien soit
vous prenez F3 tu joues du foot quoi
avec un meilleur fou que ce soit
échanger les foutres je joue le cavalier
contre Le Fossat donc bon tu as des
espoirs long terme
[Musique]
donc au lieu de 4 oui maintenant ils
aiment bien faire cavalier à 5
faux recul
et jouer avec vous aussi avec ou sans C5
et d'ailleurs mes dépôt avait battu
digne là-dessus au candidat en fait
mais les premiers candidats je pense
enfin les premiers soit 2020
bon ok
voilà et donc là lui il a fait car il y
a 5 d'abord ça change que tu économises
20 temps enfin le fait que tu rentres
pas tu vas plus vite peut-être faire C4
c'est 5 pour faire peut-être C4 ou quoi
elle est vite bon allez va faire x 2
c'est clair et je m'attends donc assez 5
dessus
c'est logique
c'est que il traîne pas
de temps
[Musique]
donc en fait ça ressemble beaucoup à ce
qu'il a fait l'autre fois de jouer pour
la case des 5 et changer le fond de la
cavalier
[Musique]
mais c'est un thème souvent en fait dès
que les Noirs font ce C5 tu peux jouer
pour Fuger 5 fous en cavaliers on en a
déjà parlé qu'en fait c'est pas une arme
d'après les ordi ou quoi mais c'est un
truc tu peux y travailler dessus pendant
longtemps quoi
dans la dernière partie
[Musique]
c'est bien joué
bon c'est pas risqué côté blanc et lui
il a pas risqué parce que il a un point
d'avance au score et tu joues une partie
que tu peux peut-être gagner et là
prendre un vraiment un break dans le
match quoi ce serait terminé
et du coup l'idée c'est peut-être de
jouer C4 avec les Noirs tu vois un truc
comme ça
une des idées de perroquet comme je t'ai
dit c'est de faire vite ce genre de truc
mais je sais pas si ça marche ici je
savais trop longtemps que j'ai plus
regardé mais peut-être
en gros là ce qu'ils veulent oui c'est
de prendre un F6 et s'installer en
dessin alors déjà vu le scénario
participe et puis voilà quoi
on va voir comment
digne de traite ça
mais je pense que si l'équipe de Néo a
décidé de jouer ça c'est qu'ils sont
sûrs de pouvoir réobtenir le même genre
de position
la stratégiquement c'est fondé quoi
après bon je sais pas concrètement ce
que ça donne etc mais de toute façon je
pense que quand tu as battu une fois un
joueur dans un style de position
vous êtes envie de refaire pour
exactement le même scénario même si
l'autre a un temps de plus ou je sais
pas quoi si c'est pas déterminant tu as
envie de refaire parce que tu as
l'impression de tu joues mieux que lui
dans ce genre de truc voilà c'est pour
ça que je pensais pour dingue demain
enfin prochaine partie blanche retenter
un Londres oui
ou
tu mets le fonger 5 ou 98
[Musique]
et il a requé pardon donc il va sûrement
prendre en F6 ici
bon tu peux faire autre chose mais quoi
en fait tu joues pour ça quoi
après le seul truc pour Ding c'est si
son équipe a eu le nez creux
même si le position et qu'ils ont pu
regarder un truc dans cette variante là
c'est pas improbable que les Peugeot ça
enfin il joue l'espagnol exclusivement
là depuis un moment
il a déjà joué le genre de position
qu'on me Ding noir affrontement il fait
des anti Marshall à tout bout de champ
et il les a très peu contre Carlson donc
en fait tu t'attends un anti-marshall
que ce soit le H3 le A4 le détroit
c'est un peu comme les révisions
d'examen peut-être si tu as un peu tu
fais un pas sur un truc
on sent vraiment qui va jouer ça tu as
révisé vraiment loin et là du coup tu
auras pas trop de problèmes ce que tu
arrives à réciter à cette coupe
maintenant voilà on est retombé
complètement dans la même genre de
position
et maintenant par contre tu peux jouer
avec ces trois avec les Blancs tu l'as
pas fait au début ça va pas dire c'est
interdit qu'on se refuse à le faire
complètement jouer ces trois pour
peut-être avancer avec des quatre plus
tard ou quelque chose quelque chose
comme ça allez peut pas faire fout des 8
fous non pas pour l'instant non mais
vas-y va nous faire le plan normal avec
G6 et compagnie quoi
ok bon
je sais pas s'il connaît en détail les
coûts mais pour l'instant il a pas l'air
trop traîné
très rapidement ça laisse à penser que
mais là il va bouffer non
bon
c'est pas faux mais je sais pas est-ce
que tu as vraiment envie dans une
situation de match comme ça de laisser
un jour les Noirs faire ça
bon oui et non enfin
il va pas faire
si il fait c'est juste tu veux faire nul
et la partie va durer une heure quoi et
pourquoi pas tu la sèches la partie mais
non
je pense pas que les blancs à la
poubelle comme ça à la rigueur quand ça
sera plus que une partie
peut-être
enfin je veux dire si elle a 13 il a
genre situation qui dit ok moi j'ai
qu'une partie à tenir vas-y mais là
c'est trop tôt pour pour ne rien faire
donc il est pas ouais il est encore dans
une situation il joue le lien avec les
Blancs
ouais mais Julien enfin il joue
gentiment
de faire nul j'imagine n'est pas mais
[Musique]
il a envie de poser deux trois problèmes
et que si Ding les réseaux bon ok bravo
annule
en tout cas les deux hommes connaissent
encore
que c'est encore théorique
je savais pas ça pourrait être enfin je
veux dire c'est Dame des deux ça
m'appeller d'être incroyable
il est où pour profiter de du jazz 17 en
partant et oui
une mise à jour
mais tu vois ici
je suis pas complètement confiance déjà
il est pas con pour ça
que ta copine
non il y a encore des parties qu'une
fois
c'est une partie de 2018
entre des gens qu'on connaît pas
c'est normal quelque part
Michel
parce que
et
l'autre partie Mitra un quelque chose
parce que c'est en train de jeter un œil
les amis en fait il y a pas eu de
parties par correspondance ça a été deux
parties de partir
bon alors Dame des deux bon écoute le
truc c'est qu'on menace
comme la dame D8 elle est à la fois la
défense de la 5 et de F6 donc les Noirs
ont plus ou moins deux possibilités
c'est soit faire Fuger 7 soit calicé 6
et je pencherais sur quelle ici
puisqu'il a plus rien à faire en A5 mais
peut-être que faut j'ai 7 et
parfaitement viable j'en sais rien moi
mais bon faut G7 après faut qu'on fasse
dans ce qui se passe sur kg 5
[Musique]
une défaite de ligne serait presque
fatale a gagné celle-ci on s'exposant tu
peux réfléchir par toi même là pour
cette question là autant
non mais ça peut être assez intéressant
de se faire la démarche intellectuelle
tu as deux parties
au blanc il faut que tu gagnes une
est-ce que tu prends le risque de de
faire à l'état 15% de chance de gains 62
défaites et
et 25 de nulles est-ce que tu risques ça
ou est-ce que tu te dis j'ai encore deux
chances avec les Blancs nul pour le
moment ça va
si tu étais dans la situation
toi temporise
il m'a toujours dit mon coach tant que
tu peux temporiser dans un toit tu
temporises en fait tu prends des risques
quand tu es obligé
donc tant que nul tu peux tac pas les
chances de gagner tu fais nul quoi
en tout cas tu joues pas méga risqué
depuis le début en fait personne n'a
jamais risqué
c'est ce que tout le monde fait tout le
temps après il y a juste
l'avant-dernière ou tu peux feindre le
risque pour faire peur à l'autre et que
ils prennent nul
ok mais tu peux peut-être risquer c'est
la trace je sais pas mais
[Musique]
là je trouve c'est tôt pour faire au lit
bon de toute façon il a pas fait au lit
blanc dans le match
tu es que des nuls
é 18 nuls une victoire tu dis bon
comment je vais gagner mais là oui tu as
déjà gagné trois fois ou deux enfin peu
importe
il a gagné une Anglaise et l'animzo il a
pas gagné justement
il en a converti 2 mais c'est quand même
beaucoup trois gagnants sur sur cinq
parties
potentiellement
tu as 60% de chance d'avoir une position
gagnante bon après ça marche pas tout à
fait comme ça mais je veux dire par là
que quand il te reste deux parties c'est
pas ridicule
[Musique]
s'il y a des partages qui est
objectivement le meilleur ambiance
rapide je sais pas moi en fait équilibré
je pense
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que se croit
plus fort
il est peut-être mais digne pendant un
moment il était bon là bon c'est
toujours pareil on sait pas où il en est
avec depuis 2020
ça fait égalité ce que c'est un
Armageddon ah non non après c'est des
partages en rapides
des Blitz c'est peut-être un Armageddon
au bout du bout de la journée si jamais
ils sont jamais départagés mais
pas de
réfléchit ça peut tanker un moment que
ouais bon après c'est timing de
réflexion c'est peut-être ça faire
finalement à la vue du match c'est ça
qui lui coûte le retard de réfléchir à
des moments un peu un peu bizarre un peu
bizarre ouais ouais après je comprends
pas qu'il est pas gagné la nimo toujours
avec et finalement une partie vraiment
mauvaise mettre en avant c'est la
seconde du match le Gambie damage 3
ouais elle est horrible
et donc c'est son regret parce que c'est
vrai qu'il la perd pas il ferait que nul
il y aurait égalité au score
[Musique]
mieux mais les pots maintient plus au
niveau stable j'ai envie de dire aussi
parfois au-dessus parfois en dessous
ouais trop souvent
trop souvent trop bas en fait
parce que je crois que sont plus sont
hauts et plus haut mais sont bas et très
bas échecs c'est mieux d'être constant
une pièce de théâtre non comme ça
l'important l'important c'est d'être
constant
on va me dire dans le chat les deux qui
cette pièce de théâtre anglais
important d'être constant Constantin
de l'importance d'être constant
du coup le personnage principal
s'appelle constant c'est ça
[Musique]
tu connais un truc à un moment donné
attention et cultivé
non mais bon
donc
Ernest donc le jeu de mots ne fonctionne
qu'en français OK
ok bon que je trouve donc un peu plus
bizarre que qu'elle est ici mais qui est
peut-être pas plus mauvais parce que
donc il y a kygi 5 possible et la
deuxième option bien sûr c'est déjà le
plan à cache 4 qu'on avait vu l'autre
fois déjà
je comprends pas la finesse en fait de
laisser mais il veut peut-être vraiment
le garder pour faire du séga 4 mais
pourquoi pas l'avoir fait dès le début
si c'était possible
mais bon il y a bien réfléchi donc il
doit avoir ses raisons mais
bon sur le principe ouais je préférais
qu'il est ici
c'est une autre histoire
c'est juste un coup qu'on m'a envie de
regarder parce que ça ça pose une
question
mais est-ce que c'est grave genre si on
fait caca ici c'est qui prend
je peux convaincre mais bon
[Musique]
complètement normal pour pour les Noirs
non
mais bon après tu vas faire tu vas faire
ces trois à quatre ou quatre d'abord ou
j'en sais rien peut-être B4 pour fixer
enfin tu fais deux trois petits machins
et puis au pire il y a rien et puis tu
feras nul et s'il y a un peu c'est
plutôt pour les blancs mais oui non
c'est pas
[Musique]
un truc assez tranquille quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre donc
ça bon c'est une option qui est
peut-être pas folle mais qui qui entre
en ligne de compte donc H4 bien sûr
qu'est-ce qui compte jouer contre
ça c'est un problème
c'est vrai je ferais bien G3 que les H4
comme ça pour roderrachins enfin
avoir
après
au bon moment donc passer le coup le
plus logique oui enfin mais oui enfin je
sais pas convaincu de
qui est ne serait-ce que vraiment
avantage ou pas ou ici avantage à quel
point mais
mais bon ok
la position que tu cherches avec les
Blancs tu as vraiment zéro risque
et
j'imagine quand même il peut peut-être
faire d'autres trucs mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils font à 5 quoi
le comprendre à ton
plus tard j'ai pas forcément
en fait si de toute façon on a envie de
faire les Cécile je comprends pas
vraiment l'intérêt de l'ordre de coup
pareil
de bien y avoir une idée mais elle
m'échappe
la vie du Grand Maître fabule coach
coach Fab
non mais je sais pas
faire en fait donc il voulait pas F5 ben
non enfin même si je jouais
en fait c'est pas si simple à faire F5
donc ils prennent sur la diagonale et
parce que j'en ai pas dans une
estonienne non plus le pion des trois il
en D3 il est pas en dessin et donc tu as
quand même un jeu plus ouvert tu as
quand même des ruptures centrales le
centre peut se s'ouvrir et donc pousser
les pions dans ton roi c'est plus aussi
tranquille que dans un centre fermé
déloger le flou blanc qui arrive ah oui
mais ça enfin
c'est sûr mais après pourquoi avoir
laissé enfin pourquoi avoir laissé
cavalier 5 et pas commencer par cavalier
si c'est probablement une raison
et on demande si il faut acheter jouable
bon on peut prendre le four il prend la
dame on prend la sienne
on va pouvoir faire F4 un jour pression
sur F7 et
[Musique]
oui
tu aurais la même position avec le pion
en C4
égaliserais tranquillement mais bon mais
il est en C2 donc tu as pas C6 dans des
cinq tu as pas son pendant quoi et tu
l'auras jamais
le X 2 le plus fort que le fou des deux
parce qu'il peut justement aller en
dessin qui peut taper sur F7 donc il
fait des trucs tu as plus avancé tes
pions les dames donc il y a des ruptures
pour les blancs pour te péter les pions
un moment et se faire une colonne donc
c'est les banques en toutes les ruptures
et qui ont les pièces mieux placées donc
belle avantage blanc là-dessus
ça serait d'énormes chances de bien
ouais non faut acheter c'est pas
possible
étonné c'est qu'il a réfléchi quand même
on a plus les temps la réflexion mais il
a réfléchi bien une quinzaine de minutes
pour fonger 7 bonne dizaine en tout cas
cavalier 5 c'est le coup évident en tout
cas qu'il faut regarder puisque tu
regardes et ça retente sévèrement donc
je sais pas c'est les temps de réflexion
de Ding je les trouve
questionnable après
pour moi il a mieux joué intrinsèquement
donc j'ai du mal à critiquer aussi enfin
ça c'est dur de dire il fait n'importe
quoi mais tu as l'impression qu'il y a
quelques petits détails comme ça qui
font la différence
alors que dans le jeu tu as l'impression
qu'il est au-dessus très légèrement mais
que quelques petites incohérences par-ci
par là mais qui sont dures à régler
après
mais qui peut finalement est-ce que
c'est lié à la pression ça peut aussi
être lié à des facteurs extérieurs
enfin peut-être que tu lui fais jouer la
même partie dans un open où il s'en fout
il clique cavalent tempo quoi
là il veut peut-être trop bien faire
quoi je sais pas
je sais pas
à voir
mais on verra on verra mais bon ouais
écoute c'est un peu plus agréable pour
une épaules je trouve en tout cas la
position
ok ici probable est-ce que
[Musique]
ce qu'on fait ces trois d'abord est-ce
qu'on prend directement le 6
il passe en voler lui non
on peut peut-être maintenir un peu le
statut
on dit il joue mieux parce qu'il calcule
plus on a bien vu que dès qu'on coupe
les temps de réflexion il fait n'importe
quoi n'est pas alors ouais non Ding
quand on coupe les cages les
cadences qui fait n'importe quoi je suis
pas tout à fait sûr il avait quand même
été le premier joueur depuis 10 ans à
battre Magnus Carlson dans des matchs de
départage rapide
donc après que sous pression il arrive
plus à se mobiliser ça je veux bien
l'entendre après dire que Ding calcule
pas bien rapide il y a quand même un pas
Fab oui oui un grand pas non mais par
contre c'est différent en plus de jouer
des parties en blitz ou en rapide et te
retrouver avec un parti lente ou tu as
déjà fait 3h30 4h d'effort que tu as été
habitué à avoir beaucoup de temps de
réflexion donc dans un autre mode de
notre cadence quoi enfin ton cerveau il
est pas là pour aller à mis à l'heure
mais plus pour faire un truc en
profondeur et là tout d'un coup tu as
plus le temps
c'est une partie de champion du monde
donc tu as le stress de faire le con en
manque de temps et donc c'est un mélange
de stress de changement de rythme et de
mise sous pression qui fait que là oui
il a mal joué il manque de réussite
c'est un tout petit peu je trouve pour
Ding parce que la position qu'il a eu
l'autre jour celle où il a perdu la
fameuse où il fait le h4h il trouve pas
le coup en fait vu comment enfin vu le
scénario de la partie là encore n'est
pas un un peu à l'image de la partie
d'hier il a un peu de bol que ce soit
pas pire ah bah oui donc il y a un petit
peu de réussite aussi qu'il faut de
toute façon quand les niveaux sont si
serrés mais tu vois j'ai l'impression
que la réussite elle a quand même
souvent tourné côté népaule jusqu'à
maintenant
oui plutôt plutôt délic ça tombe bien
aussi quoi après l'élix serait pas que
c'est de la réussite
d'éléments comme ça qui tournent dans le
bon sens ouais il a beaucoup d'éléments
favorables
mais c'est vrai que dans les parties
quand tu réfléchis entre la salle
d'avant et celle où il perd dans les
deux vraiment les positions qui tombent
c'est ouais c'est nepo il a vraiment
joué au hasard et ça tombe bien quoi les
deux fois ça aurait pu tomber très mal
en fait tu peux très bien enfin il a
fait un ennemi sur deux dans des
positions il aurait très bien pu finir à
zéro sur deux
bon après c'est aussi Ding qui perd tout
seul avec le H4 il a pas le faire non
plus mais enfin c'est toujours ça mettez
ça me fait penser un peu tennis des fois
tu regardes des matchs et tu dis ah oui
mais il a vraiment un très bon mental il
a gagné au tie-break en fait quand tu as
vu le match moi comme ça ou le mec qui
venait 6-5 au timer break l'autre il
tape une balle mais même des Nadal des
Djoko quoi il demande le local là-bas
elle touche de 3 mm
donc il fait 6 6 il gagne le 7 et bon
bah il gagne le match d'après ils disent
mais il a fait craquer au mental oui
enfin non en fait il y a pas fait crac
que mentale la [__] de balle elle est
enfin je sais pas il y a une micro
rafale de vent de 2 km heure elle est
dehors mais tu vois ce que je veux dire
ouais non mais globalement il faut se
taper ce genre de coup dans un chaud
tellement rien ouais genre là c'est un
peu ça aussi tu peux dire oui il a battu
au mental etc et c'est plutôt vrai quand
même mais d'un autre côté la même partie
la variante elle tourne mal il est
gagnant il gagne le narratif change
complètement en fait le truc en fait
c'est que le narratif change toujours en
fonction du résultat
[Musique]
vers le nombre de matchs de foot aussi
où je vois les notes des joueurs il y a
qu'en fait ils ont une note de merde
parce que l'équipe a fini par perdre
dans un très bon match et puis que de 15
occasions tu en as pas mis et puis les
autres bon bah oui enfin tu as quand
même fait un bon match c'est très
différent le contenu du résultat en fait
ça c'est deux choses différentes on doit
pas juger sur le même plan après là
n'importe lequel les deux préfère jouer
14 parties dégueulasses et de champion
du monde parce que c'est trop important
mais en général en fait si tu juges le
truc de l'extérieur tu dois quand même
décorer les deux quoi ouais mais c'est
c'est j'ai envie de dire dans le
journalisme pas que sportif mais
globalement être dans le journalisme le
résultat n'est jamais décorrélé de
du contenu en fait et nous on fait
pareil machin et tout mais en réalité
enfin voilà c'était un peu la discussion
que si tu si tu réfléchis un peu au
match avec qui il y a eu de la réussite
quand nanani nanana tu te rends compte
que ouais c'est c'est vraiment du 50/50
ça tourne un peu mieux pour Yann
le chat
important de parler de Giraudon
j'espère qu'on en parlera plus quoi mais
bon
après la gestion du temps de Digne m'a
paru quand même questionnable à certains
à certains moments et là encore
aujourd'hui quoi le la réflexion sur le
FU G7 ou tu dis bon bah il a dû se dire
sur Fougères 7 cavalier 5 je remonte la
situation mais là il prend du temps
comme on le dit avec Fabre il y a deux
coups possibles c'est qu'il sait si
c'est fou G7 puisque il y a une genre de
d'attaque une menace et surchargé le
coup le plus logique de base c'est
qu'elle va laisser 6 mais bon peut-être
c'est fou G7 le mieux mais tu dis bon
bah si tu commences par fouger ça tu
laisses cavalier 5
mais bon quand tu enfin le principal
donc tu dis bon si il a pris 13 14
minutes de réflexion c'est que bah il a
bien voulu évaluer les deux et qu'il a
dû avoir un truc sur le coup principal
cavalier G5 et donc il réfléchit très 14
minutes et tu sais pas vraiment à quoi
il a pensé puisque après cavalier 5 qui
est le coup principal
erreur plus donc c'est comme si la juge
joué le coup au hasard bah comme nous on
aurait peut-être fait parce qu'on se dit
oui bon de toute façon ce sera pas
capable de comprendre mais sauf qu'une
fin
il a réfléchi pour jouer un truc au
hasard quoi ou pas où il a calculé des
choses
ça lui a coûté dans le match ce truc de
prendre parfois du temps pour faire des
décisions sans vraiment
faut
la justifier quoi la décision là
quelqu'un qui parle je pense à la même
chose mais oui le match de l'OL contre
l'OM aujourd'hui le but contre son camp
la 99 ça change complètement le narratif
dans les jours dans les journaux bah oui
mais c'est deux Pokémon
quelque chose de complètement différent
suivant qui est ce but ou pas que ce
soit une bonne opération ça c'est sûr
mais après le jour on va mieux au moins
bien jouer parce que ils montent
vraiment
[Musique]
demande ce que je pense de l'art sonore
au goal donc c'est le goal de santé là
depuis le mercato d'hier bah très bien
il a amené une assurance et il est bon
gardien quoi je trouve ça me va très
bien je suis très content de sa présence
au club
moi en tout cas Ding ouais
toujours les mêmes les mêmes les mêmes
questions qui se posent de jour en jour
et là en plus la position c'est pas une
position qu'il avait très bien géré
enfin type de structure qu'il avait très
bien géré à la lors de la cinquième
partie du match
attention parce que c'est une balle de
match pour pour
ok donc là ça justifie on a été mauvaise
langue non mais moi
c'est une bonne décision pas ça c'est
autre chose mais justifie il voulait
sûrement vérifier à fond
ok donc là ça justifié donc ça change le
narratif mais à juste titre
voilà
non mais on peut repartir peut-être C3
ou en B4 parce que cavalue trois fois
six bah c'est ça le truc j'ai envie de
voir parce que pour l'instant c'est
forcé
est-ce qu'on fait des
plus tard ok en fait tu t'interdis
quasiment parce que
[Musique]
je regarde avec les vent parce qu'elle
est un peu en ligne droite
ici
alors
mon idée c'est pion prend puis on prend
des quatre
ok je me fais réfuter un standardeux
parce que il y a un contre cloche
mais moi en fait j'avais pas envie de
faire reprendre
j'aurais fait
puis on prend vraiment
[Musique]
avec les noirs
donc cavalier prend pion prend cavaluer
trois fois 6 sur D1
menace puis on prend cavalier prend faut
prend puis on prend dame prend
je sais pas moi
[Musique]
ok bon il veut prendre B2 à la fin si je
prends ces quatre ok dame 2 ouais enfin
d'ailleurs je dois dire qu'on peut aussi
songer à des quatre avec les Blancs
peut-être
enfin peut-être que dame c'est aussi une
option j'imagine j'adore les blancs
parce que tu as l'impression que tu as
beaucoup beaucoup d'options et que tu es
en train de choisir entre bien ou bien
bien ou mieux ouais mesdames 2 vas-y
pour voir enfin bien aussi il y a pas de
problème
bouffe 3
mais on est pas mal le X 2 il est en
muré mais un jour il sortira au pire par
B1 on fera C3 on fera un truc et
peut-être on casse assez 4 genre si on
ouais et puis en mur et vite fait parce
que en mur et oui mais d'un autre côté
il tape quelque chose moi j'appelle pas
vraiment ça en muret non mais là quand
même une pièce il est un peu pour le
moment on va dire mais oui mais on va
trouver un truc pour le sortir comme on
dit par B1 et C3 ou faire B4 bien timé
un moment en prison passant puis on
prend et refaire un deuxième B4 alors
pour l'instant les Noirs frais B4 même
mais je veux dire c'est un truc qui sera
latent à chaque coup et
ouais tu as quand même le problème du
pion des 6 à régler et tu as aussi le
problème de ton roi mais il y a toujours
un H4 5 qui est faible
HK déjà
et puis on rediscute après ça c'est net
donc
on va réfléchir cavalier prend je prends
bon on prend ça s'efforcer
c'est pas forcé mais c'est le premier
truc qu'on regarde pour justement faire
pression sur ces quatre parce qu'on est
content de voir plus on prend des trois
alors déjà il y a plus on prend aussi
ses chèques donc on est doublement
content mais quoi qu'il en soit puis on
prend des trois dame prend des trois en
terme de structure pion c'est ce qu'on
veut voir donc les Noirs veulent pas ça
on peut regarder tour C8
je pense que je bouffe ces quatre
et là il y a le choix en fait tout va
vous prendre
[Musique]
c'est chiant pour les Noirs ça c'est
kata
ouais j'arrive pas à comprendre l'idée
de Ding
je sais pas ce qu'on rate les amis on
rate quelque chose mais je sais pas quoi
on rate rien c'est lui qui a raté un
truc aussi ouais mais là les varandes
sont trop simples tu as bien avoir une
idée quelque part fois ça paraît être
écrit sur sur du fil sur du sur du
papier de verre
non mais peut-être qu'on va rentrer
là-dedans et qu'il se trouve que ça
tient je sais pas après faut voir faut
voir ce que dit leur dit mais est-ce
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui a un ordi très
fort là qui tourne en ce lundi matin bon
genre On peut demander à cesser quoi je
vais aller voir
dis c'est cousues de fil blanc moi j'ai
envie de dire que c'est écrit sur du
papier de verre
disque
0,306 et il y a un coup je sais pas ce
que c'était mais
après je sais pas c'est que si on peut
revenir en arrière je crois pas non il
te fait que du live lui
je crois qu'il a joué
je veux pas jouer en fait
je vais revenir en arrière j'ai trois
c'est trop
Fabien
non mais il dit quoi qui prend aussi F
prono 6 les numéros
trois fois H6 tourradéen tour C8 en fait
là meude
j'en sais rien et fou prend E3
maintenant dame prend et Tours C6 et il
blinde comme ça ouais c'était nathly en
fait mais basiquement tu te mets un peu
en danger avec les Noirs alors je veux
dire c'est ça peut-être qu'il va la
tenir ou quoi mais c'est pas agréable
avec les dents
moi aussi alors après lui bon il joue
l'espagnol depuis longtemps et c'est un
genre de position qu'il a déjà croisé
donc peut-être qu'il sait des trucs bon
on sait pas mais
je suis arrivé chez flippé là mais pas
disons moi je suis persuadé que les
blancs sont mieux quoi
gagnant c'est un grand mot mais
tu me donnes ça en partie en fait je
commence à me lever à faire le malin à
jouer vite
enfin là je suis insupportable si tu me
donnes les blancs
je suis content enfin
d'un mois tu me proposes de commencer la
partie dans cette position tous les
jours par là tu me vois plus une seconde
assis
là tu me vois plus tu vois plus de la
partie en fait
je viens je clique je repars
en fait c'est mon rêve d'avoir ce genre
de position avec les Blancs tu as aucun
risque tu vas pouvoir jouer pendant
longtemps tu peux commencer à te
dandiner un peu de partout dans la salle
de jeux tu es heureux tu es là tu es à
gauche à droite tu reviens tu regardes
toujours les coups de derrière ça avec
un air un peu bizarre ouais bon
qu'est-ce que tu as joué ah tiens
regarde je suis en couple je repars
ouais c'est ça moi je sors la bouteille
de champagne je l'ouvre et je quitte
avec une coupe à la main ouais ouais
là c'est oui oui bon là tu me vois déjà
avec les petits canapés ici petit canapé
saumon petit canapé foie gras je suis là
quand je croise des gens à la salle de
jeux il me demande qu'est-ce que tu as
fait oui bon j'ai gagné enfin
bon
va rentrer là-dedans c'est que
moi je suis vraiment j'étais vraiment
hyper toxique quand j'avais genre
d'opposition ah bon ouais
bon
je me lève normal mais je
[Musique]
non mais je suis content je suis
foncièrement content
il faut encore travailler pour pour
gagner quoi ouais
je peux plus perdre
et toi dans l'ouverture de Digne une
nouvelle fois
[Musique]
mais j'ai du mal à comprendre en fait
parce que
[Musique]
il y a eu des mois de préparation pour
le match tu savais que ça allait être le
temps de position
c'est juste la ligne main de espagnol
depuis 10 ans quasiment quoi donc en
gros on a un peu moins vu récemment mais
tu dois savoir quoi
et donc là mais je sais pas ça se trouve
ça tient très facilement après tout
c'est 6
infos comme ça ça peut tenir mais ça va
être long et pénible mais
[Musique]
moi j'aime pas enfin voilà
ouais
en plus je veux dire il a déjà galéré
dans le genre de position
ronde 5 tu peux t'attendre parce que le
mec a été recherché des noises dessus
quoi
[Musique]
peut-être pas assez de temps de
préparation de machin les candidats
c'était pas si longtemps finalement
c'était un an enfin attends juillet
dernier mais est-ce que tu as vraiment
le temps entre eux
[Applaudissements]
depuis septembre il a eu que 6 mois de
préparation
enfin est-ce que c'est assez finalement
j'en suis pas sûr femme
il y a déjà ça qui joue préparation
quand même très courte et
là il a été en danger autant plusieurs
fois on l'a dit il y a que deux heures
pour jouer 40 coups et voilà enfin pas
assez de jours de repos aussi ça
enchaîne quand même beaucoup en les
parties tu joues 2 jours tu as que une
seule journée pour récupérer tu
retournes au charbon le lendemain
les parties sont quand même longues
c'est parti qui dure à chaque fois trois
quatre cinq heures c'est usant
mentalement faut réviser il y a
l'histoire d'élique moi je pense qu'il
en a ouais c'est c'est juste trop
peut-être pour lui les forces physiques
est trop important
sauf que non mais c'est réel enfin genre
tu joues quand même trois quatre heures
aux échecs dans la journée
tiens regarde là les mecs qui ont fait
Liège bastogne-liège hier
c'est mardi ça commence demain mais
genre les mecs tu leur laisses quand
même 24 heures pour souffler ils ont
fait que Liège Bastogne que fait 259 km
à fond les ballons mais
voilà tu as quand même tes 48 heures
pour souffler pour aller chercher le
Tour de Romandie deux jours après ouais
puis même quand il y a des grands tours
comme le Tour de France tu as quand même
trois jours de reprend trois semaines
bah oui tu trouves le bien voilà et là
il joue deux jours d'affilée machin et
peut-être qu'il est en danger
physiquement
donc bouffe aussi bouffe aussi et alors
on s'attendait pas forcément toi tu
parles peut-être d'un Kibe 4 peut-être
qu'on a un des Français intermédiaires
mais fais voir juste pour
non mais franchement si tu bouges la
tour
tu dégages la Tour Eiffel
c'était assez sur le champ
non mais alors des Français bon je crois
pas qu'il va faire mais c'est quoi le
fou
si on prend du côté obligé impossible
bon je crois qu'il a
dû retirer le cavalier assez vite
les premiers coups qu'on avait mais il a
vérifié de très content là pour le
moment Yann très franchement dans cette
partie il a rien fait non
et puis tu me fais C4 bon bah de toute
façon j'ai pas le choix parce que
vous prend des cinq quand même
il y a deux coups
tu es obligé
sans avoir rien fait
donc
bravo
il suffit de jouer espagnol quoi pour
être mieux
ouais mais c'est peut-être un des
meilleurs joueurs d'espagnol avec les
blondes
je sais pas mais oui enfin en tout cas
ici bien spécialisé il a beaucoup
travaillé récemment de l'espagnol
essayer d'autant plus beau que Magnus
est réussi à tenir aussi simplement
finalement finalement dans
ces mars et anti Marshall etc
est-ce que dessin que je vois pour les
noirs on a regardé c'était une des plus
c'est la première ligne que j'ai regardé
les fous machin avant ouais mais ça va
être la même
bon c'est pas très jouable ça ferme
[Musique]
deux en premier enfin ouais mesdames de
tourner moi j'aurais commencé par tout
radin parce que de toute façon tu crées
une menace et dame 2 tu peux le faire au
prochain et comme je dis peut-être qu'il
va faire des Français ouais mais les
blancs il va peut-être jouer des
Français
[Musique]
je trouve que gagne il fait une très
bonne partie hein je prends C4 je prends
penser 4 et on verra et toi tu dois tu
as les pieds Damoclès au-dessus de ta
tête à chaque fois de donner le titre de
la vidéo dans tous les cas d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis bah c'est toujours la ligne
qu'on a réalisé tout à l'heure c'est ça
qui est beau dans nos petites papiers
quoi pour B8 donc l'idée c'est comme ça
lorsqu'on échange en C4 on va taper B2
donc nous on avait pensé à Dame 2 ici
bon 3
prendre la dame et on va prendre la dame
bon après avantage blanc mais avoir quoi
il y a encore du chemin pour gagner bien
sûr mais ce qu'il y a pas mal c'est que
la tour D1 on voit le tape sur des 6
donc avec les Blancs ça on fera des
pensées on aura directement une pression
sur sur le pondé et on peut aussi songer
à jouer
le coup des quatre
[Musique]
il peut ressortir le foin
les dessins qu'on nous a beaucoup posé
la question mais non toujours pas faute
d’âme prendre des cinq ben là il va y
avoir plus on prend descendre
et on va te découvrir la tronçage et
surpuis on prend on va te bouffer 5 puis
voilà c'est terminé quoi
non non il y aura jamais des éléments
les noirs très content de le faire
marcher mais il y a trop de pression
partout pour que ça marche
cavale à 5 il faut les remplacer
bon écoute on a parlé l'autre jour
donc je sais pas on verra
bon on n'est pas là personne n'est là
on retrouve le triste spectacle de la
table vide
on avait un peu perdu au cours de ce
match enfin on avait un joueur sur deux
on a les deux joueurs c'était jamais le
cas mais là depuis la ronde précédente
on retrouve un peu le numéro non pas de
soliste mais le numéro
de 0,10 mais alors après j'ai vu une
suggestion de carottes
pour éviter un peu ce problème ils vont
les salles de repos faut quand même en
mettre mais juste tu mets pas un sofa
hyper confortable et une télé quoi
tu mets une salle avec peut-être un
fauteuil mais sans télé sans fin
pourquoi tu dois avoir une télé en fait
non mais moi je suis contre la télé
ouais c'est ça en fait tu peux mettre un
sofa pour que le mec puisse s'asseoir et
boire un café en attendant il a envie
mais tu lui enlèves la télé tu tu mets
juste un écran avec blanc noir à qui
c'est de jouer mais encore il a qu'à se
démerdir venir marcher regarder la
pendule enfin comme nous on fait en
tournoi
c'est pas grave mais
oui le problème est simple à régler mais
après il doit pas être si simple à
régler quand même Fab parce que dans la
gueule aussi pour pas qu'ils aient trop
envie de rester dans dans la salle de
repos on a vu le même problème au match
de championnats du monde précédent donc
certes ça va être un problème qui est
compliqué à régler
d'organiser et d'enlever la télé
je te la débranche enfin moi je vais
gérer
d'accord avec toi merci c'est un
problème comme ça et pas réglé c'est
forcément que c'est compliqué donc ça
doit être enlever une télé c'est
peut-être pas si simple
je sais pas tu fais venir Momo et ni
en fait il est trop cher il voit fouger
7 autres
il est mauvais elle est défoncée en deux
deux quoi bon ben voilà tu as plus de
télé et fin du truc quand même fin du
problème
en tout cas c'est encore un spectacle
magnifique qu'on nous offre le spectacle
des chaises chaises vides
les caméras clinées et les arbitres qui
discutent
encore une fois renvoyé
ils sont où que tu en penses est-ce
qu'on peut venir Momo casser la télé
comment on peut résoudre ça
ce maïs humain qui a joué 7
c'est un peu perdu
[Musique]
mais ouais c'est un peu étonnant ce
spectacle qu'on vit en match championnat
du monde après
il faut que le temps coule deux fois
plus vite quand un joueur absent de la
chaise non mais la solution la plus
simple c'est juste hors troll dans lever
les télés dans la salle de repos et ça
règle le problème de de manière
immédiate et c'est étonnant que ce soit
pas fait parce que bon bah c'est quand
même les échecs un sport qui se veut
médiatique enfin qui se veut rentrer
va chercher à ce médiatiser forcément
bon ça c'est inacceptable
et moi après quand tu dis qu'ils vont
souvent aux chiottes c'est vulgaire donc
c'est plus quoi dire après c'est très
bien
magnifique qui rose autour de la table
il sait plus quoi je suis complètement
sous la table ouais
il y a quoi sur la télé bah rien ils ont
l'échiquier en fait comme nous là ce
qu'on voit bon t'aurais pas de barbe
d'évulation
en fait
voilà que ça
et donc il réfléchissent depuis là-bas
tranquille dans leur canape à se voir
leur petit thé café juges pas ce qu'ils
veulent et
mais bon
mais après moi une nouvelle fois j'ai
rien contre les joueurs parce que s'ils
ont cette option là c'est une option qui
paraît logique d'utiliser
[Musique]
c'est tout à fait normal
juste tu cliques depuis ta salle de
repos toi tu peux donner l'écran droit
digital et le truc
bah tu es une P4 en fait
tu fais une becap
mais oui comme dit flags en fait la
solution pour moi la plus simple et je
suis 100% je souscris 100% à ce qu'il
dit c'est que le plus simple c'est juste
d'enlever la télé enfin réellement non
mais je suis d'accord c'est la solution
hyper simple et efficace
pas de télé pas de télé voilà enfin
après tu peux rester en salle de repos
et réfléchir de tête mais ça te plait au
moins ça te pénalise tu as le droit de
le faire
parce que tu aurais très bien le droit
de rester assis sur les chiottes pendant
une heure si tu as envie enfin personne
peut t'empêcher de
d'aller aux toilettes donc bon que tu es
ta salle de repos aussi on te l'empêche
pas mais oui tu n'as pas de contact avec
les filles qui est
pour moi ça paraîtrait normal mais après
on doit avoir une vision quand même
assez retardée des échecs nous on pense
que les gens doivent être devant en
échiquier pour jouer et on est on est
des boomers quoi les échecs de point
zéro
même pas sûr quoi j'en sais rien
alors pas de télé puisque le repas alors
avant il y avait télé et caméra dans la
salle de repos mais à la demande des
joueurs la caméra dans la salle de repos
a été enlevée tout simplement
son petit thermos
il est meilleur le café ici
ça se trouve les pièces bougent dans la
salle de repos et en fait ils analysent
je prends mon exemple personnel parce
que moi je joue que sur Internet
et c'est vrai que les fois où je vais
jouer sur eshirel bon ça arrive je m'en
sors quand même pas mal d'ailleurs Baki
était pas bien quand il m'a vu jouer sur
elle je pensais que tu étais long et qui
arrivait pas tu veux que sur Internet
oui bon je pose quand même deux trois
bases mais ça m'avantage quand même de
réfléchir sur un 2D parce que je passe
tellement plus de temps
que quelque part moi j'irai
naturellement regarder sur la télé mais
je veux dire que c'est un comment dire
enfin c'est pas normal je sais pas en
fait non tu joues sur Echiquier 3D bon
bah tu joues sur 3D et si tu as
quelqu'un qui est plus fort en 2D bah tu
lui donnes quelque part un avantage
de pouvoir aller réfléchir sur un
échiquier en 2D mais c'est pas le but du
temps
là on rentre vraiment en quelque sorte
dans les échecs qui brillent pour moi
en fait à la rigueur s'il mettait un
échiquet je serais pour qu'ils mettent
pas la télé mais que tu es un arbitre
qui te déplace un échiquier
qui te mettent la position quoi
sur un échiquier 3D si vous voulez
mettre la partie dans la salle de repos
non mais pas besoin
ça te laisse réfléchir sur avant
ça peut donner un joueur comme moi ça
donnerait un avantage
donc du coup il a bouffé direct c'est 4
donc on s'attend à quoi il faut prendre
autrement
ouais
on ne sait plus
à ce niveau là tu peux réfléchir de tête
on nous dit non mais bien sûr tu peux
mais c'est quand même plus agréable
d'avoir la position devant les yeux
parce que si tu réfléchis que de tête
pendant des heures un moment donné
peut-être que tu vas avoir une pièce qui
va plus être exactement au bon endroit
mais ça te fatiguer un petit peu plus
même si c'est marginal j'ai vraiment
évident je peux faire de tête je peux
jouer à l'aveugle je peux c'est bon mais
et puis j'ai pas quand je vous
détournable je me balade je pense à la
partie et j'ai pas d'écran qui m'ont
transmettre mon truc donc je sais faire
quand même enfin mais du coup
si tu as l'échiquier de toute façon tu
vois un peu mieux enfin quoi qu'il en
soit c'est pas qu'on sait pas faire
c'est que bon cavalier français 4 on
nous dit on va regarder un petit peu
on comprend qu'on perd un peu davantage
donc à feu tu reprends F1 ouais mais là
tu perds quand même de l'avantage
mais bon c'est bizarre c'est pas de
jouer un peu plus que ça quoi vu la
position
donc DC cavalier prend c'est forcé
donc DC cavaliers prend fous prend puis
on prend forcer
peut-être possible mais j'y crois pas du
tout
non j'y crois pas dame prend des 6
ans
[Musique]
ce sera peut-être la partie mais qui
sera d'une incipidité totale mais bon
peut-être que peut-être que ils auront
99 de taux de précision
est-ce qu'on peut appeler ça une
coulante quand tu fais ça avec les
Blancs tu
fais nul alors que tu es mieux
moyen d'avoir une position où tu risques
rien et tu es un peu chiant quand même
là il compte pas apprécier rien on
demande ça du public dans la salle alors
je crois pas que ça ait rempli les
foules d'ailleurs j'ai regardé des
photos de l'Open d'Astana oui ah ben là
absolument personne dans la salle
cependant petite petit moment pub enfin
pub même pas trop parce qu'on fait un
événement qu'un rapport avec classecom
donc là vu que on fait le il reste plus
beaucoup de place pour la Watch party de
la proche League donc ça va se passer le
12 mai à 18h moi je serai à Paris pour
suivre le match les joueurs seront sur
internet donc ce sera un genre de stream
en live avec les supporters les tambours
les champs les fumiers sont autorisés ou
pas fumigène et donc il ne reste plus
que 25 places enfin peut-être même moins
donc il reste vraiment plus beaucoup de
place là il y en a en ce week-end il y a
22 places qui sont partis là les gens
achètent hyper vite parce qu'ils se bah
ça l'événement s'approche ils ont peur
de pas avoir leur place donc j'en
profite pour le répéter il y aura des
tambours ouais ouais il y aura
supporters avec des tambours
ah les baquis je pense que ça va gueuler
quand bah qui va jouer son premier coup
de Project League parce qu'il n'a pas
encore le premier coup je pense qu'on va
il rentre dans la saison là on rentre
dans la saison là on l'entrée de Baki
dans le match
et donc ça c'est cette joyeuse riz
se passera le 12 mai à 18h à Paris à
bispote à deux pas du Louvre pris du
billet 8 euros donc en temps dire que
c'est donné réellement là c'est on
pouvait pas faire moins avec un Power et
en plus on a négocié pendant le match
Lapi hour et la pinte de bière à 5 euros
pendant le match donc autant te dire
qu'à Paris à deux pas du Louvre la pinte
à 5 euros ça n'existe pas en fait vous
gagnez de l'argent venant quoi bah en
fait ils m'ont dit le moins cher dans
les bars à côté c'est 9 euros donc tu
bois trop trois pentes tu es déjà très
bien et donc tout ça ce sera le 12 mai
et là donc on aura un tournoi d'échec et
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui me
tient à cœur personnellement c'est pour
ça que j'organise cet événement
c'était avoir des tournois des chèques
avec du public donc là bon on sera pas
dans la salle de jeux mais on sera quand
même là ensemble on se réunira ensemble
pour suivre une compétition d'échec
donc ça ce sera c'est vraiment cool et
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à cœur
parce qu'on aura plus de public pour cet
événement là que pour un championnat du
monde c'est quand même beau c'est beau
et en plus les billets sont payants
alors que contrairement là c'est gratuit
les gens vont venir
retransmis sur twitch bien évidemment
voilà on achète où les billets alors bah
je peux vous mettre un lien dans le chat
il me faut une petite seconde pendant
que les joueurs jouent la variante ça va
faire nul il joue la variante de nul de
nul forcée
étonnant comme choix mais mes choix
compréhensibles il a voulu effacer la
partie pas envie de jouer Yann tout
simplement pas envie de jouer
dans un bon to play
je vais mettre je vais mettre le lien
comme ça vous avez l'occasion j'en
profite d'en parler aujourd'hui parce
que les places là peuvent partir très
très vite j'en ai mis j'en ai parlé sur
Twitter donc je vais mettre le lien
vous l'avez dans le chat
vous avez le lien avec la billetterie
dépêchez-vous dépêchez-vous ne vous
dépêchez pas comme comme vous le
souhaitez
c'est possible que dans 24 heures il y a
plus de place après ça peut rester
encore pendant deux trois je sais pas
comment les gens vont réagir mais là si
les gens se chauffent et qui disent il y
a plus de place et tout le monde se
bloque
si Yann fait nul toutes les parties il
est champion du monde alors ouais c'est
c'est exact mais après il prend un
risque c'est de il tombe pas sa chance
quoi c'est à dire qu'en fait il va lui
acheter deux parties
au noir sur 3 donc on sait que
normalement avec les Blancs on a plus de
chance de gagner de mettre en difficulté
l'adversaire et donc bah il soit très
confiant sur son répertoire noir et dis
bon ok c'est bon j'ai blindé maintenant
il y a plus de soucis mais là vu la
partie qu'il avait aujourd'hui et
l'option de peut-être pouvoir
créer deux trois problèmes adversaires
il aurait peut-être pu essayer un peu
plus c'était pas très risqué en fait on
va dire je mets une petite pub ça Rama
short en termes de temps la partie va
être courte donc pub rapide on revient
dans 3 minutes regardez normalement ça
va tout échanger hein les pions on va
être échanger on devrait avoir une nulle
dans moins de 20 25 minutes à mon avis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà le Fab on est dans le tour on
n'a pas eu trop de surprises dans les
coups joués mais oui ça va pas faire nul
tout de suite parce qu'ils doivent jouer
40 coups quand même
donc
voilà on a encore là une petite
demi-heure peut-être
pas une compétition de début mais avec
Maxime est-ce que c'est celle-ci
autre chose c'est un autre tournoi en
IRL
qui sera où ce grand chasse tour
alors le premier est-ce que ce serait
pas Bucarest j'ai du mal à dire quelque
part voilà
c'est pas trop après il y aura un orage
donc Norvège comme son nom l'indique
alors entre-temps au milieu il y aura un
autre grand rapide et Blitz ça n'arrête
pas là
[Musique]
d'un coup
pendant plus de 6 mois en tout cas 9
mois je pense et là ils vont enchaîner
il y aura des trois non-stop là
ok ok
donc il compte pas pour le Manchester un
tournoi assez fort
et puis petit à petit on va arriver dans
l'été et puis un autre et la Coupe du
monde après il y aura aussi les
champions sur Internet
aussi je crois il y en a tout le temps
en fait il y en a un mais un pendant le
Grand Chef toi ah oui donc les joueurs
ont pas pouvoir faire les deux
à moins que il clique vite dénudes
on a eu le cas là quand j'étais à Cavic
de Alexander fear le joueur brésilien
qui en fait c'était qualifié donc je
sais pas en quelle division il était
mais dans trois on peut donc du coup moi
j'étais pas au courant mais je le vois
ronduite ou du tournoi de l'Open je sais
pas il a des blancs contre un joueur
accessible pour lui hein 2003 2004 tu
vois enfin bon il fait nul en hyper vite
bon bah je sais pas parce qu'il a un
avion à prendre vraiment je savais pas
en fait je comprenais même pas ce qu'il
faisait et en fait non c'est que il est
en plein match de de champions et juste
entre deux parties à la pause il est
parti cliquez son tournoi l'Open et vite
rentrer à l'hôtel pour pour jouer donc
peut-être les joueurs vont faire ça
aussi on ne sait pas
et on nous demande si ce sera diffusé
alors moi je diffuserai sur ma chaîne
perso les grandes chaises tours mais
uniquement les parties de Maxime
allieresa
peut-être il y a une belle partie tu
cliques à voir pas sûr peut-être non
c'est une compétition la pro châssis par
équipe
qui se joue sur plusieurs mois donc
jusqu'à maintenant il y a eu la phase
qu'on pourrait appeler la phase de
poules ou la phase qualificative il y
avait 16 équipes au début dans cette
phase de qualification qualificatif avec
des belles équipes notamment et il y a
le Magnus Carl Seine toujours dans une
équipe Nakamura marenzel grichu qui joue
dans notre équipe et caroanna tout un
tas de joueurs de du top niveau donc
nous on a eu un match de barrage on
était barragiste pour pour la calife on
a éliminé l'équipe de Magnus Carlsen
l'équivalent du 8e de finale donc en
playoffre en match de barrage et donc on
joue en quart de finale et on affrontera
l'équipe d'Inde avec des joueurs assez
connus comme Praga Nanda
de faire notre mieux pour
pas passer de se qualifier pour
l'emporter ouais et pour aller un peu
plus loin dans la compétition donc il
veut tout reprendre
voilà ça risque d'être la fin de la
partie
même d'être aller-retour du roi merci au
revoir peut-être de m'avoir le coup 40
c'est une répétition ils ont le droit à
ça
voilà pour la compétition qui organisée
par chasse.com
c'est à cette compétition qu'on a battu
l'équipe de Magnus Carl Seine dans notre
match précédent sur un score assez
convaincant j'ai plus le score final je
sais qu'on mener 7 et demi à 4 et demi
trois points non
[Musique]
il était même un peu mieux ouais
on avait su je me rappelle Katia qui
était passé par complètement gagnant et
qui avait fini par perdre mais c'est ça
c'est Maxime qui était perdant qu'on
vend de forêt qui a pris
en dixième jour si besoin
il y a
moi je suis pas
on avait gardé une place au cas où
[Musique]
quelqu'un est pas là mais bon du coup
comme vous pouvez pas ajouter tout le
monde on a gardé un
en réalité il y avait vraiment un gros
pépin pendant un tournoi ou quoi
99,99% ouais
tu reprends le 3
je pense à faire la répétitions
à deux
c'est ça qu'ils ont calculé c'est pour
ça qu'il a pris du temps pour jouer
et Katia Katia laguenau triple
championne du monde de glitch et rapide
et ou rapide et
elle est peut-être top 5 mondiale
actuellement
et à la fin il y a de championne du
monde elle a perdu un match Championnat
du Monde finaliste championnat du monde
elle a perdu en départage
malheureusement
c'est quand le prochain match ce sera
mercredi
la nouvelle partie d'ici ouais demain
c'est repos donc aujourd'hui quand même
normal et donc mercredi jeudi
et samedi
donc demain on souffle et on revient
à fond les ballons mercredi avec donc
une partie ou Dingo ras les blancs et là
il va quand même tenter quelque chose
tu vois
l'équipe l'équipe nous sera le 12 mai
c'est pas par pays non c'est pas par
pays c'est par équipe
mais bon c'est comme dans tous les
sports en gros
genre le PSG tu es pas obligé de jouer
avec des Français quoi
oh que non
le lendemain de la journée de repos pas
spécialement c'est juste un avantage
d'avoir les blancs
que ce soit après la journée de repos ou
pas
ça change pas grand chose après là
est-ce que Yann a fait une erreur
on sera la fin du match en fait
moi je trouve bizarre de pas avoir posé
plus de problèmes juste parce qu'en fait
ça a rien dit qu'il aurait gagné malgré
tout mais
là je gère là bon bah juste il se
contente de nulle très clairement
non mais je parle du PSG ça peut être
L'Oréal si vous voulez faire un peu
importe en fait n'importe quelle équipe
est-ce que le Real peut jouer avec zéro
espagnol quoi il s'en fiche
ils ont beaucoup d'étrangers c'est pour
ça que je disais ça je crois cet exemple
mais à L'Oréal
[Musique]
par Carval
donc tu as le droit quoi
c'est pas c'est pas qu'on a coupe du
monde de foot ou c'est pays par pays
oh non
me semble-t-il
après
tu prends leur 11
ils sont
il y a plusieurs
parce que l'année dernière il croit
encore
c'est très très impressionnant
Alessandro Valverde l'éternel ouais
il a pris la retraite enfin j'ai envie
de dire
le lindster au rugby c'est vrai que
c'est l'équipe nationale d'Irlande
quasiment il y a quelques joueurs du
Monster et de lolster qui complète mais
ils sont peu nombreux d'ailleurs très
gros match en ce week-end Fab pour les
amoureux de rugby de Toulouse Leinster
qui reçoit Toulouse
ça va être dur hein ça va être très très
dur d'aller chercher sur leur pelouse
elles m'ont grosses équipes de Toulouse
mais à fou je sais pas si tu as déjà vu
jouer en deuxième ligne mais waouh il
fait mal impressionnant
le stade
ouais ça va être un énorme match
ça joue à quelle heure je peux te dire
ça
ah tu as peur qui est la partie
une demi-finale
parti 14 et 16h 16h 11h 5h de jeu
qui a fait tourner un week-end dernier
ils ont pris 67 à deux contre les boules
ok ils ont pas aligné un joueur en fait
il se prépare à fond
ça va être
le match d'avant ils ont mis personne
non plus
ça prépare
miser avec personne c'est un peu la
finale avant l'heure non aucun non ok
non parce que les gens
[Musique]
et puis La Rochelle attention ils ont
pas gagné parce que Exeter il a réussi
c'est pas très bien
même s'ils sont à domicile sur leur
pelouse je pense s'appelle le stade
Marcel de Flandre
ça peut ça peut être compliqué ils ont
pas été serein contre bluester attention
attention avec des terres même si ils
sont énormes favoris
le match se joue à Bordeaux en plus
voilà bon
ça se joue au Matmut Stadium à Bordeaux
ouais bon là c'est et ça peut leur
coûter cher
délocalisation
c'est Bayonne cette année qui gagne tout
à domicile donc tu vois et qui joue
éventuellement pour un pour une
peut-être ils sont allés se
délocaliser un match en Espagne en
Pays-Basque contre
mais quand tu vois la saison tu dis oui
il y a quand même des chances c'est
dommage tu gagnes tout chez toi là ils
ont encore battu Montpellier avec un
superbe drop de Camille Lopez
tu te dise aurait pu peut-être battre
pot à domicile et ouais parce que à
Baiona quand même
qui parle dans le chat quoi ils sont là
c'est une chanson qui a été créée en
collaboration qui est supporter du RCT
ah oui parce que les supporters du RCT
sont amies de de l'Aviron Bayonnais
[Musique]
par les paris de vie je suis briviste à
essai durant comme saison pour Brive ils
sont où là ils sont dernier donc
les Catalans
tours
c'est la même
qui a l'avantage c'est complètement nul
c'est
juste qu'on attend que qu'il fasse nul
mais il y a 100%
[Musique]
du terme suicide là pour
la petite discussion rugby
mais ce soir et ce week-end il y a aussi
samedi en plus le
6 nations féminin avec un Angleterre
France à 14 heures
se taper des banquiers au lieu de suivre
le match Fab et qui regarde peut-être le
live en ce moment même d'ailleurs et
qu'ils doivent pas être bien quand on en
parle ça doit suer un côté
du coup on nous demandait peut-être
ouverture demain qu'est-ce qu'on pense
bah moi je dirais
trois fougères un truc comme ça
ou une viennoise
[Musique]
au pire tu le refais une fois que tu
proposes nul mais à un moment ils
avaient fait cette histoire avec débile
que tu devais jouer 40 coups à coup sûr
trois fois même position au coup de 18
tu devrais acheter 22 fois
je me souviens d'une partie je crois
maso contre Myrine championnat d'Europe
ils font du lac en moins de 20 coups
mais la partie
doit intervenir et fixer la nul
bon ben nul
il y a pas grand chose à dire sur cette
partie on nous a parlé du cahier
d'exercices aussi
l'exercice je te laisse en parler
pendant que je chope
fantastique ça y est il est il est en
préventes
donc qu'est-ce que vous avez c'est un
petit livret de 80 pages donc quand même
du beau Caya quoi avec quasiment 300
exercices je crois qu'il y en a 286 si
ma mémoire ne me trahit pas des quiz des
mots mêlés des petites questions culture
générale tout ça quoi et donc des
exercices classés par thème tactique
donc
voilà un peu tous les thèmes les plus
classiques et
classé par ordre difficulté croissante
on va dire et voilà donc sympathique et
surtout prix d'achat très attractif à
moins de 10 euros donc
très très accessible et je pense
sympathique à dire
j'ai mis le lien si vous voulez le
trouver en précommande il est en
précommande Amazon et vous serez livré
normalement officiellement le 25 mai
pour être expérimenté dans les
précommandes j'ai vraiment pu ressent un
jour avant peut-être même le 24 donc là
attention magnifique dans un mois
voilà vous avez le lien si vous
souhaitez le retrouver ben nous il est
déjà l'heure de vous quitter mesdames et
messieurs merci d'avoir suivi cette
partie courte
on va dire
et on se retrouve après demain alors
pour la suite de ce championnat du monde
merci à tous bonne journée ciao ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]